let's go to the next call let's go to
rachel in blackfoot idaho rachel good
morning how are we doing
good morning i'm all right how are you
outstanding outstanding
how can i help this morning um i just
have a friendship i want to move on from
but i'm worried about her mental health
and i don't know how to
like do that oh that's a good one man i
get this question
all over the country so walk me through
your relationship
um well we actually met because her
husband was cheating on her and i found
out and let her know like that's how we
became friends
oh wow welcome to it right yeah
that i mean that kind of write-off gave
us like a deeper connection just because
i knew something about her that people
didn't know and so she started coming to
me with other stuff she's divorced since
then
and is now dating but i've just noticed
a lot of behaviors that like i can't
support
and she doesn't like if i tell her
or call her out on it she either ignores
it
or like once she threatened suicide when
i called her out on something
and i just feel like it's not a
relationship that i want to continue
because it's
bringing me down and not making me feel
good like i just have a really hard time
helping someone who doesn't want help
and i feel like she's
i don't know in all her relationships
she uses and uses
and uses and doesn't give anything back
and then i don't know
it's just a hard relationship so what
what
what joy do you get out of this this
relationship
well i care about her since i know her
and i that's about
all of it i don't know if there's really
any joy i just feel almost obligated
because i care about her and i
worry about her and i know she doesn't
really have anyone else to confide in
and so i i don't know i feel guilty
leaving it but i don't feel like there's
any joy there
is there a part of you that likes being
the hero or liked it until it got to be
a lot
um some i that's kind of what i do in
general yeah with all my relationships i
like helping people and
i have a hard time walking away when
it's not serving me
i just keep helping and helping until it
breaks me
gotcha so number one i would
strongly consider you find somebody in
your life that you can be honest with
and vulnerable about that tendency
my guess is you're somebody who's
attracted these type of folks forever
and if you're a safe place and you're
somebody that
um knows things or has some past
experiences that you can share that
makes you a safe place but it also makes
you a
magnet and another way of thinking about
it makes you a target
for folks who are soul suckers
right that yeah they just live to absorb
other people almost like a dementor
and but at the same time there's a
benefit to you especially at the
beginning right
um it feels good it feels good to be
wanted and be the smart guy and
the smart gal and be the one who knows
things other people don't know that
feels awesome
and man you're gonna end up in the same
situation where your friends become your
albatross
and just you're always treading water
and it's exhausting
right yeah um so here's my rule of thumb
for folks like this
number one if anybody in my sphere ever
whether it's my longest oldest friends
in the world
and i still am in close contact with the
guys that we all grew up on the same
street like when we were zero together
um if anybody in my sphere threatens
suicide i call in the calvary i don't
screw around with that i don't mess
around with that
and i also am real clear about with my
friends and community
after that happens once or twice then
i'm not your go-to person for that 911
is your go-to person with that do not
call me with that again
does that make sense because you they
are choosing
i've got to set my boundaries and
somebody else is continuing to jump my
boundary
with something on fire and throw it at
me and
i've said i don't want that in my world
okay and you have permission to do that
um the second one is if somebody
weaponizes suicide
um that can drain everybody around you
and so again
that's for professionals to deal with
not for you
right and so pass that along i also
think it's fair to sit down and have a
hard conversation about your boundaries
and for somebody who does like it when
people reach out to them they do
like being the go-to person that's going
to be a hard conversation for you to
have
but the boundaries of i love you if you
are struggling with x y and z
i can't provide you support and
assistance for that so i want you to
call a professional
i won't be a good resource for you there
because i don't know what to do and
that's
weighing me down that's bringing a lot
on me and
i'm unequipped to handle it if you said
words like that and really draw
firm boundaries and then you followed it
up with but i do like hanging out with
you
if you're fun and you're exciting and or
you're just regular sad right
awesome but if you just want to use me
as a trash bin i'm not going to be a
good person for you
and so how how would how would you go
about having a hard conversation like
that my guess is you've never done that
before
um i've done similar stuff before i've
oh yeah
good for you yeah tell me about it so
like i try to do that but
um yeah i don't know how i would do that
with her because i feel like it would
just
turn into her sobbing and telling me how
much she needs me and how much i've
meant to her and that
she can't believe that i'm doing this to
her and i i just feel like it'd be used
against me
and it might be and so the way i would
ask you to reframe it
is not something you're doing to
somebody but something you're doing for
yourself
okay and if she is truly mentally ill if
she is truly struggling with
self-harm with suicidal ideation if she
is truly struggling with
some of these heavier things you're not
equipped to handle it
and by dragging it out you're you put
yourself in a position to actually hurt
somebody
by continuing to accept and continuing
to accept and so
often one of the greatest things we can
do for people who don't know how to have
relationships they don't know how to
to lean up against boundaries
appropriately they don't know how to be
socially aware
is to teach them what a true boundary
looks like
and what true love with boundaries looks
like
and then they're adults and they can
choose to accept those boundaries or not
accept those boundaries that's their
decision not yours
but at the end of the day making sure
that people are safe is priority number
one if you've got a friend who says
going to hurt themself
call somebody call somebody call 9-1-1
if you don't have a hotline number handy
we'll put a hotline number down in this
show's show notes
we've done a couple of shows where we
put hotline numbers in there make sure
you have
a number where you can call if you've
got people like that in your life but
also
um draw firm boundaries i remember a few
years ago
i was speaking to a parent at one of the
universities that i worked at
and i let them know you can tell your
kid you cannot talk to me like that
you can tell your child you can't your
adult child you can tell
your adult friends do not call me
at 2 am when you're intoxicated and
dump the following on me we will have
those conversations in person we'll have
those conversations around coffee
or you will have those conversations
with a professional i'm not that person
i'm not equipped for it
um it would be the same as me inviting
friends over to do
like crazy workout programs and i'm not
in shape or they're not in shape
that's not being a good friend that's
just me trying to show off or
dump stuff on them or make them feel
less than or whatever
but people aren't there to be used
they're not tools people
are relationships right they're people
to be with and so
anyway i can belabor on this all day i
get this question all the time
the key is to look in the mirror and
draw your boundaries and establish them
and like i first started talking with
with with rachel here
um most people who find themselves in
this situation
actually liked it at the beginning they
liked being the go-to they liked being
the connected person to oh yeah
learning hard things and then they
realized very quickly
carrying that weight around is is
exhausting and
people like that tend to absorb you they
they look for that energy
and they just just again dementor is the
only thing i can think of but
and here's the thing we are heading into
a season
um where this is going to happen more
and more
it's going to happen more and more so i
want to back out
30 seconds 30 000 feet here and
remind everybody before covet hit
we were all totally fried stressed
burned out we were already out of gas
and we were able to
um you know compress our sadness we were
able to
hide our frustration and exhaustion
through busy and busy and busy
and buying things and running and
scrolling through things
we were able to just kind of shove it
aside we were able to
wallpaper over the cracks and our
marriages and in our friendships
with busyness and kids soccer games and
another dance recital another thing
another thing
and then covet hit and we all had to go
home and we all had to stare at each
other
and stare at each other and then some of
us across the country are still having
to just stare at each other
but before kovit we were seeing a
massive increase across the country in
what researchers are calling diseases of
despair
and diseases of despair are suicide
organ disease failures like liver
disease
heart disease those are diet related
those
are often depression related and
in an increase in addiction and so the
average lifespan in the u.s had actually
gone down the last few years before
covet hit and these were all diseases
of compression diseases of despair
to nerd out a little bit if you take a
normal bell curve
some have even taken to calling this
long tail suicide
which means people aren't acutely
killing themselves
they're not using a gun or pills or
something like that jumping off a bridge
but they are coming home from work they
are
overweight they are grabbing poison out
of their pantry
or poison out of their fridge or they're
driving through and grabbing some poison
they are sitting on the couch and
drinking and numbing and eating
and lonelying themselves to death
it's a cultural country-wide crisis
and it's not even cult it's not even our
country it is turning into a global
thing
we are just so spun out and so exhausted
and good folks this was before covet
right
and so i was checking out the data
recently on
the covet related mental health issues
and there is just
expert after expert after expert
predicting what they're calling
a far worse mental health pandemic
that's going to last for years and years
beyond covid
major increases in hotline calls
major increases in telehealth referrals
and calls
during covid some of that is great i'm
glad people are using these resources
but it's
it's again anxiety alarms they let us
know when we're disconnected
when we are in situations where we don't
have control
or our lack of predictability and
or when we are scared when we are
fearful and that's what covet has done
to us man
so here's what i want people to be weary
of i want them to
get on their guard a little bit i wanted
to exhale
start making plans again because here
we're coming into winter
and the we we have
had outside adventures we could just go
for walks we've had sunshine we've had
outside events we've started figuring
out ways to do outside kid things right
we were able to walk our dogs and all
that we're getting into winter
when it is cold and it is dark and our
tendency naturally is just to stay
inside
and we are going gonna have to be so
intentional
so intentional about living lives that
don't
compound this already growing anxiety
this already
growing depression that's already
growing inner this inner dysthymia
oh and by the way we have an election
coming luckily it's not a contentious
election and everyone's on the same page
so that's cool
good good grief